The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
OK, let's get started.
On Thursday, we are
really privileged to have
Jon Bentley, who is one of
the masters of performance
engineering, come and
give us a guest lecture.
In 1982, he wrote this
wonderful little book
from which we
adapted the Bentley
rules that you folks have seen.
And he's also famous for
things like kd-trees.
Who's seen kd-trees. trees?
Yeah, so he invented kd-trees.
And who's ever used the master
method of recurrence solving?
He invented the master
method of recurrence solving.
And so he's just a
wonderful, wonderful fellow,
with lots and lots of insights,
and just a superior performance
engineer.
And he's going to give a
guest lecture on Thursday.
And so I would encourage
you to bring your friends.
Bring friends maybe
who dropped the class,
and others who if any of
you have UROPS, other people
in your research group, whether
they're graduate students,
they're all welcome to come.
Because this is really
one of the opportunities
you get to actually meet one
of the legends of the field,
if you will.
And you'll see he's
very approachable.
He's very approachable.
So anyway, my advertisement
for Jon Bentley.
Good.
So let's start.
I want to talk about speculative
parallelism for a little bit,
because that's kind of what you
need to make the code go fast.
So if you look at
code like alpha beta,
it turns out that it's
inherently serial.
That is, if you try to
do things in parallel,
then you missed the cutoffs.
And if you missed
the cutoffs, then you
start doing work that
you wouldn't necessarily
need to do.
And so the only way to sort
of make this type of code run
fast is to use speculation.
Which is to say,
that you're going
to guess that you can
do stuff in parallel
and it'll be worthwhile, and
then, occasionally, you're
going to be wrong.
But the trick is, well, how do
you minimize the wasted effort
when things go wrong?
So let's just take a look
at a very simple example
of speculative parallelism,
which is thresholding a sum.
So here we have a little program
that is returning a boolean.
It takes as input
an array of size n.
So thresholding a
sum-- we have an array
of length n and a limit.
And these are all
unsigned integers, say.
And I start out the sum at
0, and what I'm going to do
is add up all the
elements of the array.
And if it exceeds the limit,
then I'm going to return.
And so how might I optimize
this code a little bit?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Split up [INAUDIBLE]
four processes, [INAUDIBLE]
split up an array [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: No,
let's say on processor.
On one processor,
what might you do?
AUDIENCE: In the
middle of the loop,
you can check [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Yeah, once you
check so that once
you would exceed it,
why keep adding
the other numbers?
So here's a code that
does that-- quit early
if the partial product
ever exceeds the threshold.
This isn't necessarily
an optimization.
Because notice that now
in the optimization,
not only do I have a memory
reference and an addition,
I also now have an
unpredictable branch.
Actually, it's
predictable branch--
predictable branch.
But it's still one more
step, because it's always
going to predict that it's not
exceeding until it actually
does exceed.
So that'll be
pretty predictable.
But still, I've added
something into the loop
so that maybe slower.
How might I mitigate
that problem?
So I don't want to add too
much into the inner loop.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It could
have an inner loop
that goes [INAUDIBLE] them.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yeah.
So basically, I can do
what's called strip mining.
I replace the loop of n
iterations with a loop of,
let's say, n over
four iterations,
with an inner loop
of four iterations.
And every fourth
iteration, I check
to see whether or
not I've exceeded,
so that the cost of the check
is going to be relatively
small at that point.
So are there ways of making
this sort of go fast.
So now, we want to make
this operate in parallel.
And the problem when
I operate in parallel
is that as I'm adding
stuff up, I want to do it.
So I'm going to do this
here with a reducer.
And so, basically,
I'm going to add up
the values in the reducer.
But now, I'd like
to do the same thing
of being able to quit early.
And so the question
is, well, how
can we parallelize a
short-circuited loop?
And so, the way I'm going
to do this-- and this
is sort of by hand
here, but it's
going to give you--
so actually, as you
know, underneath the
loop is really a divide
and conquer loop.
And so I could write
it as a parallel loop.
And now, it becomes, I
think, a little bit clearer
how I could, in
this case, what I'm
going to do is return
the value of the sum.
And now the question
is, well, how
can I quit early and save the
work if I exceed the threshold?
Understanding that
when I'm executing
this and something
like Cilk, it's
going to tend to
go down one path.
And often, it's going to
be a serial execution.
So I'd like if it's possible.
So here's one way
of doing it, which
is that I add an abort
flag to the code, which
is going to say whether
I should keep going
or whether I've actually
exceeded at that point.
And so I'm going to
use that recursively.
And now, I take a look, for
each time through the loop--
or through the
divide and conquer--
to see whether the sum
is greater than a limit.
And I haven't you know
already aborted the flag,
then I set the abort
flag to be true.
Why do I bother
testing the abort flag
before I set it to true?
So notice that setting
the abort flag is a race,
isn't it-- a determinancy race.
Because-- great.
Thank you.
It's because I have the
stuff operating in parallel
is all trying to set the abort
flag whenever something aborts.
I can have two guys who
are in parallel setting
the abort flag.
But if they're
setting it, they're
setting it to the same value.
So it's a benign race, assuming
your memory model is such
that you can actually
set the values.
So what happens here when--
why do I why do you
bother checking this?
So what happens when
several guys in parallel
want to write to
the same variable?
This is quiz 1 stuff.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Cache bouncing.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yeah.
You can have it bouncing
along the cache.
It will serialize it.
Because if they're
all trying to write,
then they have to get
exclusive access for it
to write and modify it.
And so that happens-- boom,
boom, boom-- one at a time.
And so by checking it first,
it can be in a shared state,
and then one guy
clobbers it, and then
it will update all
the other ones.
So it makes it so
we don't continually
have a true sharing race.
And then in checking
to see if it exceeds,
we basically just check to see--
we basically call this function.
we set the abort flag to false,
and then we return the
sum of all the values.
And if it aborts, then
it just returns early.
So it doesn't have to keep
going through the computation.
And, of course, once
again, you can coarsen
the leaves and so forth.
So this is nondeterministic
code, which we should never
write unless we have to.
Because that's the only
way of getting performance.
And you have to make sure you,
of course, reset the abort flag
after the use.
And then, actually, do
you need a memory fence
here on the abort flag?
Do you need to set--
where would you
put an abort flag
to make sure that
the value was--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe do it by
setting default [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yeah.
So what would you have to do?
AUDIENCE: Put a [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: OK.
So indeed, it turns out you
don't need a memory fence here.
And the reason is because
the code is correct,
whether it's the
initial value false
or whether it's become true.
So it doesn't matter
when it becomes true.
And so there's an issue of,
if you put in the fence,
then you know that it
becomes true earlier,
rather than waiting
for the computation.
But that may actually
slow things down,
because memory
fences are expensive.
But because the
transition is always
from false to true
during the execution,
you don't actually need
a memory fence there
in order to make sure that
you've got the correct value.
Does that makes sense?
So you don't need
a memory fence.
So that's a classic instance
of speculative parallelism.
It occurs when
our program spawns
some parallel work that
might not be performed
in a serial execution.
So you're performing
it, anticipating
that you're probably
going to need to do it.
And then, typically,
what you want to do
is have some way of backing
out if you discover that you
didn't need to do it that way.
Have some way of making sure
that you don't do any more.
So basic rule of speculation
is, don't spawn speculative work
unless there's little other
opportunity for parallelism
and there's a good
chance it will be needed.
So one of the things I've seen,
in research papers, no less,
is people who say, oh, I'm going
to have a calculation where
I'm trying to find, say, the
minimum of a bunch of values.
And so I'm going to spawn
off n things, each of which
is looking for the minimum.
As soon as the minimum
one comes back,
I'm going to retract all
the other computations.
And I'm going to get super
linear speed up that way.
Because in the
serial execution, I
might have done the
longer one first.
And maybe the minimum is not
the first one or whatever.
And so they claim
super linear speedup
by doing speculative
parallelism.
But that's not really
a good example,
because there was a
better serial code.
If that was really a
good way of doing it,
they should have
been doing what's
called dovetailing,
which is doing
a little bit of
this computation,
a little bit of this,
a little bit of this, et
cetera, and then going back.
That would have been a better
algorithm for which you
would then use it.
And the risk they have is
that they're spawning off
n things, of which most
of them may not be needed,
and now they don't
get any speed up,
even though they've just
used a lot more work.
And that often is a bad choice.
So usually, you don't
want to speculative work
unless there's little
other opportunity
and there's a good
chance it'll be needed.
My experience is, what
kind of chance do you need?
You need to have
certainly less than--
for parallelism, if the chance
that you're going to need
the work-- if you
have p processors,
if the chance that it could
be not needed is less than--
actually, I have a
theorem at the end which
all which I've
I'll refer you to,
because it's a little
bit hard to say,
because I didn't
put on the slide.
But there's a final
slide for this,
which gives a nice
little theorem about when
you should do this.
So now, let's talk about
parallel alpha-beta search,
because that's
kind of what you're
doing with your principal
variation search.
So if you remember the analysis
done by Knuth and Morris,
they basically showed
that for a game
tree with the branching
factor b and depth d,
and alpha-beta search
with moves searched
in best-first order
examines it exactly
b to the ceiling of d over
2 plus b to the floor of d
over 2 minus 1 nodes at ply d.
So that's basically square
rooting the amount of work
that you would need if
you did a full depth ply.
That's with alpha-beta.
So naive algorithm looks at
b to the d nodes at depth d.
And so for the same
work, the search depth
has effectively doubled, or
the work is square rooted.
So that we solved last
time in Helen's lecture.
So the key optimization here
is pruning the game tree.
And as I mentioned at
the beginning of this,
when you prune the
game tree, you've
got what's effectively
a serial thing.
And if you let
something go ahead,
you may be working on
something that would be pruned.
So then how does the parallelism
really help you there?
You're just wasting processors
that could be better
spent perhaps elsewhere.
Except, where else
can you spend it?
Because there's no other
parallelism in the code.
So we want to find
some solution.
So the solution
comes from an idea
from a very nice paper
by Burkhard Monien
and some of his
students in Germany.
And they made the observation
that in a best-ordered tree,
the degree of every node
is either 1 or maximal.
This is not their
observation, this
is actually the observation
in the Knuth paper.
So when you have a
best-ordered tree,
if you can get all the moves
ordered in their true order,
then it turns out
that either you're
exploring all the children
or you are refuting something
and you get a cutoff
from the very first one
that you look at.
And so in this case, for
example, it turns out,
on the principal variation,
those are all full-width--
sorry, you have to
explore all the children.
And then from there
on it alternates.
One level, you have
just a single child
that needs to be explored.
And when you explore it,
if it's best-ordered,
you will get a beta
cutoff for the others.
And then it alternates,
and then it's full-width.
And so their idea
was to say, well,
if the first child fails
to generate a beta cutoff,
speculate that in fact
you have the best one,
and the remaining children
can be searched in parallel
without wasting any work.
So if it fails,
you're going to say,
oh, I'm going to
speculate that this
is in fact a full-width thing.
Now, in practice,
you don't necessarily
get things
best-ordered, but there
are a bunch of heuristics
in the code we've given you
in chess code to make it so
that you tend to do things
in the proper order.
The most important of those is,
if you've seen the movie before
and it's in the
transposition table,
you use the move that
you've seen before, even
if it's to a shallower depth.
You guess that that's going
to be their best move still,
even if you search deeper.
And that's pretty good.
And so they call that the young
siblings weight algorithm.
They actually called it
the young brothers weight,
but in the modern era, we
call it young siblings weight.
And we abort subcomputations
that proved to be unnecessary.
So you're going to
start out searching,
but then you want
to get rid of things
that you discover, oops, I did
get a cutoff from searching
from one of these things.
I don't need to do this.
Let's not have it keep
spawning and generating
work and some other
thing, let's abort it.
And here's the idea for
the abort mechanism.
So what you do is--
the abort can occur
at any given node.
You get a beta cutoff--
you want to abort all the
children that wouldn't
have been searched anyway.
But they may have
already been spawned off.
So they have a record in
each node that tells you
whether or not you've aborted.
And what you do is you just
simply climb up the tree
to see, periodically,
whether or not
you have an ancestor
who is aborted.
If you have an ancestor
that's aborted,
it says I'm aborting
the side computations,
then you say, oh, I'm done,
and I just have to return.
And so you check that
on a regular basis.
So do people follow
what that mechanism is?
And so, that's
basically what you're
going to be implementing
for the parallelization,
is this thing of climbing up.
You're going to guess, after
you've searched one child,
that it's good.
Hey, actually some
people say, why don't you
check two before you
search the others,
so that you're even
more sure that you
don't have a cutoff, because
neither of the first two
aborted.
Because, in practice,
of course, the game tree
is not best-ordered.
And so you're going
to waste some work.
But the idea is, you're
going to pull up the tree
to see whether or
not-- and, of course,
you don't want to pull on
every evaluation that you do,
you want to just
pull frequently.
So you may have a
counter in there
that says, OK, every 10th time,
I'm going to pull up the tree.
You put a voodoo
parameter there that says
how often it makes sense to
actually check, because there's
cost to going up and
checking versus exploring
more of the tree.
And so, I have an example here.
And I think this is where
I'm going to cut this short.
So there's an example, which
I suggest you take a look at.
I want to, as I say, spend
time doing Q&A, and talking
about the other
parts of the program,
and give you folks some
good ideas for the thing.
So this is sort of
the theory thing,
and then I have some slides
that will explain this
with examples in more depth.
Because I don't
expect that everybody
got every detail of this.
So I have some examples
and so forth in here
that I'm going to let you
guys look at on your own.
Now, if you parallelization
the spawning
off loop of the
younger siblings,
you will get a code with races.
And the reason you get races
is because there are several--
the are three data structures--
that the search is employing
that are kind of global.
The first is the
transposition table--
looking things up to see whether
or not you've seen them before.
That's a major optimization.
You don't want to get rid
of the transposition table.
And so you have a choice
with the transposition table.
What are you going
to do with it?
Are you going to lock it
so that the races become--
at least your data-- race-free
and updated atomically.
Or you could replicate it.
For example, you could have a
worker local copy of the data
structure, and each worker
that is working on it
only accesses their
own local copies.
Or you can make a copy
when things are stolen
or you can make just one
where you maintain it locally.
Or you can decide that, well,
even if there's a race there,
the odds that it's going to
affect how I play in the game
are not that high, so
I'll run with the race.
Because any other solution is
going to be more expensive.
And then maybe you
get funny answers.
So one thing for that
kind of data structure,
let me just recommend
that you have
some way of turning
of the data structure
so that you can actually
do the parallel search
and get deterministic,
repeatable results.
So even though it
may be aborting
and some things may
not be aborting,
you want to have some
way of executing.
And so, for example,
you want to be
able to turn off even the
speculation in your code,
so you can test all
the other things
in your code that don't
depend on the speculation.
Because if you have something
that's not deterministic,
as I say, it's a
nightmare to debug.
So you're going to do
the evaluation function.
Hey, if you're testing it,
turn off the speculation.
You should be able to find
out whether you've got bugs
in your evaluation function.
There's no point in
discovering you of a bug,
and it's like, well, where
did it come from or whatever.
So you want to have
things you're turning out.
And also, want to have
ways of turning off,
for example, access to
the transposition table.
Yes, I'm going to
speculate, but no, I'm
not going to access
the transposition
table in parallel,
because I may get
a race on the entry in
the transposition table.
The hint that I will
give you for that
is that in the code
for our program
that took second prize in
the world computer chess
championship many years ago--
I think it was in 1999--
where we actually almost
won the tournament,
and we lost in the playoff.
We would have won
the tournament,
except that our programmer
suggested a rule
change at the beginning
of the tournament
that everybody agreed
to, and then we
were on the short end of that.
Otherwise, we would have
been world champions.
And that was the
last competition
against computers that Deep
Blue, the IBM computer that
beat Kasparov, the
human [INAUDIBLE],,
just a few months later.
They performed it.
And they placed third
in the tournament.
We tied for first.
Our only loss was to Deep Blue.
And we were running on an
1,824 node supercomputer
at Sandia National Labs, a
computer that probably is today
less powerful than this.
But it was very big
type of computation.
They basically said,
if there's a tie,
they're going to base who
wins on strength of opponents.
So you take a look at
your opponent's records,
and if you had
stronger opponents,
you'll win against somebody.
And we said, you
know, if there's
a tie just between
two programs, we
should really have them
face-off against each other
as an extra round.
And everybody said,
yeah, that's a good idea.
And then, wouldn't
you know, at the end,
we had the strongest
opponents, and we
were tied with
another program called
Fritz-- an excellent program.
And we were outsearching
Fritz in the playoff game.
And then we saw a
move that afterwards,
when we were able to do
offline searches deeper,
we were outsearching
them by like 2 ply.
But then there's
a move that looks
like it's a good move for the
depth we were looking at it--
doesn't look like
a good move if you
search much deeper, or frankly,
if you search much shallower.
It was one of these
things where it just
looked like a good
move for the ply
we happened to be searching.
Because there's no guarantee--
because you can't see
the end of the game--
that if you search
deeper you're actually
going to beat somebody else.
Because there's the
horizon effect of you just
simply can't see what's
coming up in the future.
You can only see
sort of on average.
So we made this bad move.
We almost recovered.
We almost tied.
Had we tied, we would
have been world champions,
because we had the stronger--
we won the tiebreaker.
And we weren't able to
recover from the error.
And so we took second prize.
It was like--
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, in that
program, we decided
that we were just
going to let there
be a race on the
transposition table.
And the reason
was, we calculated,
what are the odds
that the race actually
affects the value that you
would actually pick that value?
And if it affected
the value, what
are the odds that it affects the
move that you're going to make?
And if it affects the
move you're going to make,
what are the odds
it affects the game?
And if it affects the game,
what are the odds that affects
your result in the tournament?
And when you've figured
all these things out,
it was like, eh, we would
slow the program down more
by putting in, for
example, locking--
because that would slow
down every access--
than we would if we
just ran the thing.
Because one of the things
that happens in alpha-beta
is if you get an extreme value,
usually those are lopped off.
Because if it's such
a good move for you,
your opponent's not
going to let you play it.
So if you ended up with
a score that was extreme
because it was based on a
value that you were racing on,
usually it's going to
not even propagate up
to the root of the tree.
So anyway, we just ran
naked, so to speak.
So there are two
other data structures
you going to have to worry
about to make decision about.
Another one is the
killer data structure.
So the killer data
structure is a heuristic
that says, at a
given depth of code,
you tend to see the same
moves that are good.
And a move that is good for
one thing at a given depth,
tends to be good
for something else.
So for example, it may be that
you play bishop takes queen.
So you've won the
other players queen.
And then their response is
to do something irrelevant.
Well, now you mate them.
Well, there's a
lot of other moves
where you could make them on
that move, for which they're
playing things on the
board that are irrelevant.
and.
So the same type of move
tends to be a killer--
always, you're able to, at
that depth in that position,
make the same move.
And if they don't
address the issue,
that's always a
good move to check.
And so that ends up being
ordered near the front.
So the killer table
keeps track of that.
And I think, in our code,
we have two killers.
Is that right, Helen?
I think it's set up to allow you
to do for up to four killers,
but we only do two in the
code that we gave you.
And you can enable it and
see whether four killers--
but that's a shared
data structure.
And so one of the
questions is, should you
be keeping a local copy
of that or should you
be you using a global one that
they all share and updating it?
The third one is
the best move table,
which is used to order
all the low order thing.
So the first thing
that's most important
is, did you get a move out
of the transposition table?
That tends to be quite accurate.
And the second is, did you get
a move out of the killer table?
And finally, it's,
statistically,
how good are these moves?
Have you seen
these a lot before?
If you've seen
them a lot before,
that's how the other
moves get ordered.
And that's kept in
the best move table.
And once again,
that's a shared table.
In the search, you're going
to have to figure out,
do you want to do a
thread worker local copy,
or do you want to
synchronize it,
or how are you going to
manage that data structure?
And the answer, I
would say, is different
compared to what you do
with a transposition table.
The transposition
table, generally, it's
not worth locking or whatever.
And it is good to share.
Because if you have
seen that move before,
that saved you a huge
amount of computation
to be able to look
it up and not do it.
So those are some of the tips
for parallelization, which
we'll get to in the beta 2.
But now, I want to
talk about, for most
of the rest of the time,
some of the other things
that you can do with the
code you've currently got.
And let me take
these in some order,
and then we can ask questions.
So opening-- who's contemplating
doing an opening book?
Anybody?
For beta 1?
Are you going to do an opening
book for beta 1 or beta 2?
For beta 1, let me see.
OK.
Beta 2?
Who wants to do an
opening book better 2?
Final?
OK.
Yeah, OK.
So the idea here is to
precompute best moves
at the beginning of the game.
So, well, we know what
the starting position is.
So why don't I spend $1,000
or whatever on Amazon,
and compute things
to some ungodly ply,
and see what the best moves are
at the beginning of the game,
and put that into a book so
I don't have to search those?
So that's the idea.
I think, to begin with,
there are lower hanging fruit
than the opening book.
If you look at it, you're
going to be an opening
book, if you're lucky,
for six or eight moves.
And the games tend
to last-- have
you looked to see how
long games tend to last?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: No,
most games don't go 4,096.
We don't let them
go that long anyway.
So did anybody take a
look, statistically,
to see how long games are?
I think they tend to
be like 40 or 50 moves.
I mean, this year is
different from other years,
because we have different rules.
But I think it's
like 40 or 50 moves.
So you're not spending--
you're doing something that will
help you in 10% of the game.
Whereas there are
other places you
could do it which are going
to help you in the whole game.
Nevertheless, we've
had teams that
did a great job on opening
books and clobbered people
by having a fantastic
opening book.
It's actually cheaper to
keep separate opening books
for each side than to keep one
opening book for both sides.
And in this game, it's
actually fairly easy
to keep a symmetry
thing and basically
have one opening book that
works for the side on move.
And that allows you to store.
You don't have to store--
if I make a given move, if
I have a given position,
I only need, in
principle, to store
one answer for that position.
Whereas, then, my opponent
may make any number
of moves for which then I only
need to know one move-- what's
my best move in that position.
So you can see that
you have, once again,
this property, that
on my move, I only
need to have one move stored.
My opponent's moves, I need
to have all the moves stored.
And then my move, I
have one move store.
And that basically means
that you're effectively
going twice the depth, as
if you kept all my moves,
and then all of
the other opponents
moves, and then all of those.
Because when I do
that, it's like, well,
why do I need to
know the best move.
So it's better to
keep them separate.
When you build the opening
book, you'll store a lot less.
You'll have a lot
smaller storage.
You'll be able to store a lot
more moves if you do that.
But I would say, not
necessarily the first thing
I would go to optimize.
But it's also the
case that this is
a place where one of the
teams built a fabulous opening
book one year.
And one of the things
about the opening book
is it allows you also
to sort of threshold
and say, in a given
move, I don't just
have to have one move.
Let me have three moves and
pick randomly among them,
so that I'm not predictable.
What the team did that used
the opening book is they
observed that everybody was
searching from the beginning.
So they were all finding
exactly the same moves
at the beginning of the game.
And so they knew
exactly what the path
was that all the other
programs were going to follow.
And so they could make the
best move on their move.
But if you have something that's
got some randomness to it--
and there is a jitter in there.
Who found the randomness--
the place we insert
randomness in the code?
So I think Zach had a
comment on Piazza about that.
So there's a place
in the code where
we dither the amount so that you
will get unpredictable results.
And that way, you won't always
play the same move, just
by changing things.
Because a hundredth of a
pawn value is not very big.
And who cares whether
or not we have--
these heuristics
aren't measuring things
so closely that we care
about a hundredth of a pawn.
So you can dither
things and have
one move be better than
another and not really affect
the quality of the playing.
So it is a good
idea to do something
to not be so predictable.
But to build a full
opening book, that's
a lot of work for beta 1.
For beta 2 and the final,
yeah, you'll get to that point.
The next thing is
iterative deepening.
Do people understand how this
part of the search code works?
Yeah?
No?
Let me go over it.
So you can imagine, say, I'm
going to search to depth d.
And in fact, instead of
just searching depth d,
we do a depth 1 search.
If you look at the code there,
there's a depth 1 search.
And then we do a depth 2 search.
Then we do a depth 3 search.
Then we do a depth 4 search.
And we keep doing that until
our time control expires.
Why is that a good
strategy, generally?
Well, first of all, the
amount of work with each depth
is growing exponentially.
So you're only
spending, in principle,
a constant factor more work
than you would if you searched
to depth d right off the bat.
But the important
thing is that you
can keep move
ordering information
as you search deeper.
And the move
ordering information,
remember, we want our searchers
to use best-first move ordering
so that we get all the
cutoffs we can possibly
get for pruning.
And so by searching it
easier, actually you
end up with better
move ordering.
Because when you find that same
position in the transposition
table, you say, oh, well.
I didn't search it as deep
as I need to search it now.
So I can't use the value
that's in the transposition
table for the position, because
maybe I've searched something
that's ply 8 in the
transposition table,
but I've got it
searched to ply 9--
not good enough a search.
But the value-- the move
that you've found at 8--
that's probably a
pretty good first move--
pretty good guess at best move.
So by doing iterative
deepening, you actually
get the move ordering for all
those intermediate positions
really really, really strongly.
Because that transposition table
is the very best information
you've got for what
the your best move is.
And also, as I mentioned,
is a good mechanism
for time control.
Is that clear?
So that's why you bother.
It's one of these things that
looks like it's redundant.
Why are you
searching-- if you're
going to search to depth d,
why search to depth d minus 1?
You're going to that
as part of depth d.
Well, no, because you're
going to get move ordering
information that's going
to be really valuable when
you search to depth d minus 1.
So when you search
to depth d, you've
got much better pruning
than if you just
went straight to depth
d and had no information
about the move ordering.
Does that makes sense?
Endgame database--
so here's the idea.
If there's a few enough
pieces on the board,
you can precompute the outcomes
and store them in a database.
So for example, the most
common database to come up with
is the king versus
king database.
So if you do King
versus King, that
means that it's not that you
expect the game will end up
as king versus king,
it's that you're
going to encounter
that in the search.
It'd be nice to know who has the
win if you're King versus King.
Now, the code actually plays
optimally for king versus king.
The code we gave you will play
the king versus king perfectly
well.
And, in fact, there's
just two heuristics
that are responsible for that.
One is called k
aggressive heuristic,
which basically makes you
move towards your opponent.
And the other one is
the k face heuristic,
which makes you point
towards your opponent.
And those two things turn out
to do a pretty good job of when
there's one there's
two kings and playing,
they go through
this little endgame.
Did everybody do that
by hand, by the way?
Did you play king versus king?
A really good idea if you
want to understand the game
is just go and do a king versus
king version of the game.
Get an eight by eight
chessboard and just put down
two tokens kings that have
orientations, and then just
you and a friend, just try to
see if one can mate the other.
And you'll see that it goes
through a very ritualistic type
of behavior which ends up with
one of the Kings being mated.
So it's nice to know
which one it's going
to be so if you encounter that.
But here's the
question, how many games
actually make it to an endgame?
Once again, you have to look
at what the odds are there.
Because if games are
ending in the middle game,
there may not be
any need to search
all the way to the endgame.
So that's something
that you need to weigh.
Now, if you do an
endgame database,
it doesn't suffice to just
store win, loss, or draw
for a position.
And the reason is because
you can get into a situation
where you've got a
winning position,
and then you say, OK, well,
let me move to another winning
position, and another
winning position,
and another winning position.
Oh, and I'm back at my
original winning position.
And I just keep going
around in a circle,
always in a winning position,
never moving towards the win.
And that, of course,
will end up in a draw.
So you need to know
which direction do you
go for the winning position.
So the typical thing
you do there is you
keep the distance to
mate to avoid cycling.
So instead of keeping
just a boolean value,
you say, here's my
distance to winning.
My distance to winning is 6.
Now, when I'm
searching, I don't want
to go a distance to
winning that 7 or 6,
I want to go to
distance to winning
that's 5 when I make my move.
So it's very
important to make sure
that you maintain the distance
in order to avoid cycling.
Quiescence search-- we
talk about quiescence,
which is to make sure that when
you're doing the evaluation
you're not in the
middle of an exchange.
So you zap their pawn, they're
going to zap your pawn,
or maybe even zap your King.
And you don't want evaluate
in the middle there.
And so the idea of
quiescence is that when
you're done with
the regular search,
you just play off moves
that involve captures,
and then you evaluate
the position.
So that's quieting the position.
Make sense?
Another heuristic there
is null-move pruning.
In most positions,
there's always something
better to do than nothing.
So sitting still
is usually not as
good as actually making a move.
And so, the idea is, suppose
that I can forfeit my move,
and search a shallower
depth, and I still
have the best position--
then I still am winning.
And it generates a cutoff.
Then why bother exploring
any other moves?
I probably am in a really
good position here.
OK And if I don't manage to get
a cutoff from the null-move,
then I do the full depth search.
So the place this is
dangerous is in Zugzwang.
In chess, it's called
Zugzwang situations.
So Zugzwang is a situation
where everything is fine,
but if you have to
make a move, you lose.
So usually, having the
advantage of a move,
that's called the initiative in
chess, and that's a good thing.
You want the initiative.
You want to have the extra
move over your opponent.
But there are some situations
where if you move, you lose.
And so you want to
make sure you don't
have a Zugzwang situation.
I don't actually know
if there's a Zugzwang
situation in Leiserchess.
So if somebody
comes up with one,
I'd be interested to see
that, where if I had to move,
I lose--
but if I sit there.
So in chess, what they
do, is in the end game--
that's when Zugzwangs come up--
they turn off the
null-move pruning.
So is this clear what
null-move does for you?
What's going on there?
I see some people
who are quizzical.
Anybody want to ask a question?
I see some people with sort of
quizzical looks on their faces.
So the idea is for
null-move, my position
is so good, that even if
I do nothing, I still win.
So I don't want to search
anymore in this part of it,
because I get a
beta cutoff, you're
not going to let
me make this move--
the move that got me here.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: That was it.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: OK.
That was it.
OK, good.
My move is so good, I can
do nothing, and I still win.
And so why bother?
Let me verify that
without necessarily
doing as deep a search.
So null-move is
fairly cheap to do,
and it often results, in a
lot of positions, for cutoff.
And if I don't get a
cutoff, then I just
do the normal search.
This is a pretty complicated
piece of code, isn't it?
Pretty complicated.
There are other situations.
We mentioned killers.
There's also move extensions.
So typical move extensions
that people look at
is you grant an
extra ply in chess
if the king is in check,
or for certain captures,
or if you have a forced move.
So suppose you have
a move and it's
the only move you can make,
then don't count that as ply.
So you can search
deeper along lines
where there are forced moves.
That's what they do in chess.
In Leiserchess, not quite
so clear what you do--
which ones you would
do extensions for.
Because it's rare
that you have just one
move in Leiserchess,
compared to an in chess.
By force move, it's like,
if you don't do this,
you're going to get captured,
or mated, or what have you.
So that may come
up in Leiserchess.
But anyway, it's
something to think about.
So the transposition
table, we talk
about this as a search
tree, but it's really a dag,
because I can get to the same
position by transposing moves.
This guy does a, this guy
does b, this guy just c,
this guy does d.
It's the same thing
by doing a, d, c, b.
I transpose those
two moves, and I get
to exactly the same position.
And so I'd like not to
search that position again
if I've seen it.
And that's what the
transposition does.
There's a quality score that is
in the transposition table that
tells you how good
to move you've made.
And the quality is
essentially the depth
that you had to search
in order to establish
the value that stored in
the transposition table.
And so you don't want to use
something of too low quality
when you're searching.
If you have to
search the depth d,
something of quality d
minus 1 is not good enough.
Because, otherwise, you'll not
be searching the full tree.
But something typically
that is deeper--
if I'm looking at depth
d and I find something
in the transposition table
that's d plus 1 or d plus 2,
that's great to use.
That just gave me
an even deeper view
of what's behind that move.
And so if you look
at the logic there,
you'll see that
that's how they do it.
It's very tricky.
One of the things
that's tricky is
when you find a mate, how you
store that in the transposition
table.
And you'll see,
there's special code
for handling mate positions.
And the reason is
because what you're
interested in doing
when you find a mate is
knowing your distance to mate.
But not from that position--
the distance to mate from
the root of your search.
So, for example, let's say
this is the root of my search,
and I search down
to a given point.
And now, I do a lookup in
the transposition table,
and I discover that
there's a mate in 5 here.
And this, let's say I've
searched 9 ply or something.
Well, if I store that
this is a mate in 5,
and I store the
value for mate in 5,
then if it makes it
up to the top here,
it thinks there's a mate and 5.
But there isn't a mate in
5, there's a mate in 14.
So when you look it
up and you discover
there's a mate and
5 in the table,
you have to do a little bit of
a calculation to translate that
into being a mate
in 14 as the value
that's going to be used here,
rather than a mate in 5.
Does that makes sense?
So you'll see, that's the logic
that's in there for dealing
with mates.
So a mate basically takes
a very large number--
way larger than all the
material on the board--
and then it subtracts
what your number of ply
is to get to mate.
So some big number--
I don't know, 32,000
or something--
minus the depth to mate is
how you represent a mate.
So it's some very,
very big number
and then minus the depth.
And that way, you can
make sure that you're
going for a mate in 13
instead of a mate in 14,
for example, preferring that
you take the shorter path.
Makes sense?
So that's one of the
things to look at in there.
And there's also a
lot of stuff in there.
The transposition table has--
we talked about caching--
it's actually a k-way
associative cache.
And so you can vary
k to see what's
the best choice of how many
entries you should have.
The more entries
you have, the longer
it'll take you to search them.
On the other hand,
the more likely
it is that good move
stay in the cache.
So you can decide what's
the right trade-off there.
So there's a good tuning
optimization there.
Questions?
Any questions about
transposition table?
Transposition table is
a major optimization.
So Zobrist hashing--
so most of these, Helen
talked about at some level.
But I wanted to give a chance
to have people ask questions.
Nobody's asking questions.
I came here for Q&A.
All you're getting is A.
[LAUGHTER]
So let me explain Zobrist
hashing again a little bit.
So Zobrist hashing--
very clever idea.
So we have our board with
a bunch of pieces on it.
That's probably the wrong
number of squares, right?
That's seven by six.
OK, who cares.
So the idea is that
what I'm going to do
is have a table
of random numbers
that I'm going to
compute in advance.
And this is going to be indexed
by my row, my column, my piece
type, and my orientation.
And every different combination
of row, column, type,
and orientation corresponds
to a different random number
in the table.
So we have some sort
of random number there.
And what my hash
function is is it's
the XOR of all of the
values of all the pieces
that are on this table
with their orientations.
OK so if I have a king
here, that's a white king--
I guess I need to
know not just what
the type is, I also need to know
whether it's white or black--
so the side.
I think, actually, that
gets encoded somehow.
But in any case, I
think maybe in the type
we actually keep whether it's
a white pawn or black pawn.
Yeah, it's in the type, I
think, is the way we actually
implemented that.
So there's white king, black
king, white pawn, black pawn,
or space.
So if I have a king there, that
corresponds to a certain value.
If I end up with a pawn here--
let's say, a white pawn--
then that will be another
one, and I XOR those together.
And I take the
black king and I XOR
his position is, and the
black pawn, XOR that in.
So I XOR all these four values.
That's the hash
function that I use
to do things like look up things
in the transposition table.
Now, if I had to
compute this every time
I changed the position, that's
if I have a lot of pieces--
how many pieces I've
got, 7, 8, 16 pieces?
Each side has seven
pawns and a King.
So 16 pieces-- I have
to do 16 XORs in order
to compute my hash function.
So Zobrist hashing
is really clever.
It takes advantage
of that XOR trick
that I taught you in the first--
no, it wasn't the first, it
was in the second lecture?
Yeah, the bit tricks lecture.
And that is that XOR
is its own inverse.
So if I want to
remove a piece-- let's
say I'm going to move this
pawn from here to here.
So I remove this piece.
What do I do to my hash
function to remove a piece?
I look up the value for
that pawn in the hash table
and I XOR that into
my hash for the table.
And I now have a hash for
those three pieces left.
Does that make sense?
So I have my hash
function, which
is a hash of the four things.
I'm not sure you guys
can see very well there.
And I simply XOR it with
the hash of the pawn
that I removed in this case.
And now, I moved it to here.
So what do I do?
I look up that one and
I XOR that value in here
for the new position--
the new pawn position--
and that gives me, now,
the hash for the new table
with the pawn in that position.
So any move that I
make, I can basically
update my hash function
with only two XORs.
And XORs are very fast.
They're one instruction.
And they can do lots
of XORs and stuff.
So this is actually a very,
very cheap thing to do--
a very cheap thing.
So that Zobrist hashing, that
you can keep these things up
to date.
And that's something
we implemented for you.
That's an optimization
that was a freebie.
We could have given you
the hash function like this
and had you implement
that, but this
is one of the ones we gave you
as a freebie for optimization.
You're not all saying, thank you
very much, Professor Leiserson?
[LAUGHTER]
No, in some sense I took away
an opportunity for optimization,
didn't I, there?
And so in the
transposition table,
there are records for the
Zobrist key, the score,
the move, the quality,
also a bound type,
whether it's upper,
lower, or exact.
Because when I return
something from alpha-beta,
I only know a bound on it, if
it's greater than alpha or less
than beta.
And in some sense, the age
of how old is this move.
Because as things
get older, I also
want to age them
out of the table.
There are several
aging things there.
And you'll see the best
move table also has
an aging process, whereas every
time it updates the values
and gives a new value, it
ages all the other values
so that they gradually
disappear and aren't relevant.
One of the ones that
people get confused about
is the Late Move Reductions--
so-called LMR.
This is the situation where
I'm going to do, let's say,
my parallel search
of all my moves.
And the question is--
once again, you're trying
to prune everything you can.
And so the idea is, which
are the moves that are more
important to search deeper?
The ones near the beginning
of your move list,
if it's sorted in
best-first order?
Or the ones towards the
end of your move list?
So where is it most
important to search deeply?
For things that you
think are possibly
the best move or the ones that
you think are the worst moves?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Search
for the best move.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Yeah, it makes sense
to search the best moves, right?
So the idea is,
well, if something
is way down on the move ordering
list, why search it as deeply?
It's probably not
as good a move.
And so, let me search
it more shallowly?
I probably don't lose
much of an opportunity
to discover that that's
actually is indeed a bad move.
There's a reason that got
it ordered down there.
And so that's a
late move reduction.
So with a good move
ordering, a beta cutoff
will either occur right
away or not at all.
So you search the first
few moves normally,
and then you start reducing
the depth for moves.
I believe, in our code,
we have two numbers where
we reduce by depth 1 after
a certain number of moves
and reduce by depth 2 after a
certain number of other moves.
Those are things
that you can tune.
I wouldn't tune them very much.
I don't think.
And once again, I could
probably be wrong here,
and someone will discover,
oh, if you tune it like this,
it's way better.
But that's the idea of
the late move reductions.
Probably one of the most
important things to think about
is the representation
of the board.
Right now, we represent
the board as it is.
That's a terrible
representation.
It's very time-consuming.
There's sort of two
major ways you can do it.
Oh, I didn't put
the other one here.
Well, anyway, one of
them is bitboards.
Here, you use a 64-bit to
represent, for example,
where all the pawns are on
the 64 squares of the board.
And then you can use
POPCOUNT and other bit tricks
to do move generation and to
implement other chess concepts.
So if you're looking
to see what are
the possible places a pawn
can move, and you want to say,
can they move right?
And let's say it's stored
in row major order,
you can just do a
right shift by 1,
and that tells you
where all the places
that those pawns could move.
And now, you can just
pick them off one bit
at a time to generate
your move list.
And then you can do it that way.
If you're going to
move up a thing,
well, then you're actually
doing a shift by or down.
You're doing shift by how much?
By eight, to move up
or down, if you're
storing things in row major.
That makes sense, right?
So if it's 8 by 8, and you're
keeping a bit for each thing,
then if I want to generate
where is this one?
If I shift this whole thing
stored in row major order
by 8, if I shift it right,
it basically puts it there.
So I'm moving by 7, 8,
and 9, that gives you--
and then shifting
it by 1 or minus 1
gives you this, or left by 1.
And then, similarly,
you can do by shifting
by 7, 8, or 9 that way.
And I can generate all
the possible moves.
So that's one way of doing move
generation is using bitboard.
And there are a lot of things,
for example, that you can
do with bitboards in parallel.
Because you can say, did
I make a capture here?
Or let me use a bitboard to
represent where the laser goes.
Did I make a move that is going
to affect the path of laser?
Because one of the
major optimizations
you can do is in the evaluations
in dealing with the laser.
Because you're
spending a lot of time
stroking out laser positions.
What's the point of doing that--
if you made a move
of something and it
didn't affect where the laser
goes why bother doing it out?
You can just cache what
the value of the laser is.
And there are a lot more good
stuff on the chess programming
wiki.
So, yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: How do you
[INAUDIBLE] a right shift when
the [INAUDIBLE]
if the shift by 8,
and it's clear when it
falls off [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yeah.
You got be careful there, right?
Because if I do a
shift to the right,
for example, what'll I do?
I'll just do a mask to
eliminate all the things that
got wrapped around.
So two instructions or whatever.
Yeah, details.
Yes.
Details are good though.
Good question.
Whose timed their program?
Where are the
opportunities that you
see for performance
engineering for a first pass?
What are the expensive things?
What do you have as
an expensive thing?
AUDIENCE: Add laser paths--
[INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Sorry the?
AUDIENCE: Marking
the laser path.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Marking laser path, yep.
Good.
What else is time expensive?
AUDIENCE: Laser coverage.
[INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Yeah, laser coverage.
Boy, that is really expensive.
That is really expensive.
So where else is expensive?
What else is expensive?
So I would definitely
go after l cover.
That's a huge one to go after.
One of the things, by the way,
if you are making your changes
to the code and you're going
to change the representation,
leave the old
representation there.
Take it out at the end.
Add the new
representation and put
in assertions that say
that things are equivalent
or whatever.
But don't get rid
of the old stuff,
because you'll end
up with broken code.
And definitely, used
things like perft
to tell you whether or not you
made any change If you touch
anything with move generation.
So where else is expensive?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
the laser [INAUDIBLE]??
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Sure.
How much detail do you want?
How it actually works?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: OK.
So what is supposed to do
is figure out how safe--
the idea is, I want my laser
to get closer to your king,
and I want your laser not
to be close to my king.
And if I can move
into positions where
my laser is closer to your
king but your laser doesn't
get closer to my King,
that's a good sort of thing.
But when we say get
the laser close, what
happens when I've got, say--
let me do it this way--
a position like this.
So here's the--
OK.
Suppose I look at this position.
How close does the laser get?
Let's say I'm black here,
and I look at the laser.
Well, the path of laser is it
bounces there and goes across.
So I didn't get very
close to the king there,
but I'm one move away from
getting it pretty close.
Because if I just move
this guy out of the way,
now I've got it
really quite close.
So if I compare that to,
let's say, a situation
where instead of
the pawns are there,
let's say a pawn is here.
Now, the laser is actually
closer to the King
than it was in the
first position,
but it's a much worse position.
The first one was
much better when
I had the pawns here and
here, because I was simply
one move away from
getting it really close.
And so if you use just
the direct laser thing--
and we did some tests on this--
this turns out to be not very--
it doesn't guide the
program very well
on getting into situations
where my laser is
getting close to your king.
Does that make sense?
So then we said,
well, how should we
measure how close
the laser gets?
So what we said is,
well, let's take a look
at all the possible moves
from here of one move
and then look to see
how close we get things.
And the way we did
that is we said--
actually, Helen and I
worked on this really hard,
because this is a new
heuristic that we have not
used in previous years.
And it works great, it's
just slow as anything.
But it works well, so
you have to evaluate,
is it worth doing something
if it's really slow?
It may be that you'd do better
to use a simpler heuristic
and get deeper search
than it is spending
a lot of time evaluating.
But anyway, we gave you
one, that if you can make it
go fast, should be really good.
So the idea is
that what we do is
we look at all the different
paths from moving any one piece
and look at the
paths of the laser.
And what we do is we go we
count 1 for every position
that we go away--
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, et cetera.
We actually add an extra
value if we bounce off
an opponent's--
how much do we add, Helen, do
we add 1 or 2 if we bounce off
an opponent?
AUDIENCE: 2.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
I think, 2.
Yeah.
So if this is an
opponent's pawn,
we would basically go
from 3 to 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
And we basically do
that for all the moves.
And the way we
combine them is we
take the minimum number
that I can get there.
What's the what's the cheapest
way I can get to every square
that the laser goes?
So we take all the different
moves, we stroke them out,
and we take the minimum.
So if I have another
path, let's say
by turning the king
it will go this way,
and there's a you know
there's another one here
that's my pawn, then I may get
there in 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 7.
And so then this would
become a value of 7 here.
so that's the first
thing is we basically get
a map of how close are things.
And the second thing
we do is say, well,
how valuable is it to have these
to be near the particular king?
And then what we ended up
with is something where
if I look at the
distance that I am away--
let's say, this one,
for example, is one row
and one column away,
this is 0 row 0 column--
we use, I think, it's
1 over the row plus 1,
times 1 over the column
plus 1, as a multiplier
to weight how good it is that
we've been close to the king.
And we invert these
values so that it's better
to have a smaller number
there, and then we add them up.
We don't quite add them up.
No, I'm sorry.
What we do is we
look at these things
as a fraction of my
shortest path distance.
Sorry, that's what we did.
Yes, I'm sorry.
That was a previous heuristic.
So here, for example--
let's say this is the 9--
the shortest way of getting
there is 1, 2, 3 4, 5, 6 7, 8.
So this would actually,
when we do the conversion,
would give a value of 8/9
for being in that square.
So we didn't get it.
Whereas this one, the
shortest path distance
is 7 because of this path,
and you can get there in 7.
This would have a value of 1.
So this is better.
And so we do that
for all the squares.
So we get a fraction
of how much do we do.
And then we wait it by
something like this,
which falls away quickly.
But it's important, in
heuristics like this,
to have a smooth path, so that
you can get things closer.
If I made all these
things be 0, it
wouldn't know that it could move
up and get a little bit better
in the second or third
order digit to get closer.
And so then we add
it all up, and that
ends up being a
number, we discovered,
that's sort of in the range of--
what did we figure
the range was there?
It was up to like
4, or so, right?
Something like 4 would be the
maximum value it would be.
And then we said,
OK, then we have
this magic constant multiplier
that you can play with,
that says, OK, let's represent
that as a fraction of a pawn.
How much is that worth?
And we multiplied by that value.
So that's what we're doing.
So that it makes
it so that we do
tend to move our
laser closer, we
subtract how close the
opponent can get from us,
and then we say
that's the evaluation.
Now, if you have a better way of
determining whether a laser is
getting close than this one,
that's cheaper to compute,
that's good.
For first pass, I
would just simply try
to make this go fast.
Because for many of the moves
that you're going to look at,
it's going to be moving
this pawn to there.
Nothing changed.
There's no point in stroking
this out, and calculating
all the minimum, et
cetera, because it
didn't touch the laser path.
Things that are going
to touch a laser path
are things that you
move on or off the path.
So why bother?
And so if there's a clever
way of caching it so that you
can do things, that's good too.
Any questions about other
things that could be done?
So another place, I'll tell you,
that's a good idea to look at
is--
especially once you get this
heuristic top rate a little bit
faster--
is the sorting of moves is
actually pretty expensive.
Once you figure out,
here all the moves--
there are a lot of moves--
now you go through
and you do a sort.
And if you think about it, in a
best move order tree, sometimes
you only explore one of those.
So why'd you bother
sorting all of them?
On the other hand, sometimes
you do need to sort all of them.
So how you optimize
that sort so that you
don't waste time sorting
stuff that you're not
going to actually
ever explore, that's
another opportunity
for optimization.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: How do you sort
the moves [INAUDIBLE]??
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: The moves
are sorted by these things
like--
there's a sort key in
there that represents
a whole bunch of things,
like whether it was a killer.
If it's a killer or it's a
transposition table value,
it's a very big value.
If it's a statistical thing
that the history table says,
historically, this has
been a pretty good move,
then you get another value.
And then exchanges get
ordered and so forth.
So there's a bunch
of things that
are where you end
up with information,
and then it sorts those things.
So that's actually kind
of complicated logic
in terms of what the actual
values that are used there.
But the idea is, here
all the moves, now
let's figure out what's our
best guess as to what they are.
Most of the good
moves are coming out
of the transposition table.
But sometimes, the
transition table it says it's
not a very good move, and
there may be a better move.
So the quality of what you
get out of transposition table
is good, but that doesn't
mean that that's always
the best move.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yeah.
Any other questions about
what should be worked on?
Let me just make sure I--
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Where does
that sorting happen?
I've never [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Where
does the sorting happen?
That happens, I think,
at the move generation.
Is that where it is?
Is it stored in the
move generation?
AUDIENCE: In search.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Or is it in search?
I think it's in search.
I think you're right.
Search calls move generation
and then sorts it.
I think that's right.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: So one
of the things we
did that we were
providing [INAUDIBLE],,
we have a very tiny
board implementation.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: A very
tiny board implementation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
You can do a lot of
matrix on it as well.
But it's like maybe [INAUDIBLE]
replace it everywhere.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what's
a good strategy?
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Well, as
I say, keep the old one around.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
still use [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Well, you use the old one
while you're still
getting the new one right.
It's also good to be able to
go from old representation
to new representation and
having conversion functions.
But, yeah, making representation
changes, painful, painful.
And boy, if there
was one tool I would
love that would automate stuff
like that, that would be it,
to be able to change
representations of things
and still have things go well.
I should have
mentioned, by the way,
the other representation
besides bitboard.
Another one is just to
keep a list of the pieces
and their positions.
Because that's going to
be smaller than keeping
this great big board.
And do you keep this list sorted
or do you not keep it sorted?
But the advantage of
that is, particularly
as the game goes on, that
list gets shorter and shorter.
And so if you're doing less
in manipulating the board
position, that's
generally a good thing.
AUDIENCE: So for the
board reputation,
my recommendation is to
refactor all the board
axes into a function.
And then you would still
use the old representation
in the function.
Then you can validate that you
refactor everything correctly.
And then you can easily change
the board representation
to whatever you want
and keep changing it
without having to do it a
lot of refactor after that.
So find all the board axes and
refactor that to a function
call before you modify it.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yeah.
Because the compiler
will inline that stuff.
So putting in a function call
is not necessarily a bad idea.
And if it doesn't, you
can put it in macro,
and it'll be effectively
the same thing.
So great idea.
Great idea.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Anything
else that wasn't
there that you would highly
recommend for us to look at?
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Testing, testing, testing.
If you can test and know
that when you make a change
it's correct and
that you're not--
that's probably the number
one hole that people go into
is they don't test adequately.
So having good test
infrastructure is good.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Some questions
about codes counts--
I saw on Piazza
there was [INAUDIBLE]
if the beta changed the
[INAUDIBLE] count will
stay the same.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
As long as you're
doing it deterministically, yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But even the
references limitation
is nondeterministic
serially for [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
That's because there's
a randomness thing.
There's a little variable,
and you can set the variable
to be not random.
And then it will be.
AUDIENCE: Is that a part
of the set option RNG?
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: When that's set,
it's still nondeterministic.
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
Run serially?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I checked the-- is
there anything else that
should be done?
Or should it just
be that seed option?
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
I think that's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON:
[INAUDIBLE],,
can give to her the mic?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
Did you try the things
that [INAUDIBLE] include
[INAUDIBLE] like [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I got out of the opening book
and I set the RNG option.
AUDIENCE: OK Let
me test it again.
Because when I tested it
, it was deterministic.
So [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES E. LEISERSON: Yeah.
It shouldn't be--
if you run serially,
the only things that
should be doing things is
if you're doing--
it should be deterministic if
you turn off the random number
generator.
So as I say, that's
put in so that it
will behave nonpredictably.
But that's exactly
the kind of thing
you want to find right
at the beginning.
So that's exactly
the thing is find out
all the ways of making
it deterministic,
and that would be really
important for beta 2.
So Thursday, we have Jon
Bentley, legend of the field,
opportunity to meet a celebrity.
Bring friends.
He's going to give
a great lecture.